et notre invité politique pour cette
émission spéciale depuis le salon de
l'agriculture c'est Marc feno bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nos ministres
de l'agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire on est ensemble pendant 25
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice wesser Redon du
groupe Ebra les journaux de l'Est de la
France bonjour Fabrice bonjour Oriane
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation on a évidemment beaucoup de
sujets à aborder avec vous d'abord vous
êtes mise de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire en 2017
Emmanuel Macron promettait de relever ce
défi de la souveraineté alimentaire du
pays est-ce que l'agriculture française
aujourd'hui est en capacité de nourrir
sa population alors évidemment elle est
en capacité de nourrir sa population la
question c'est il y a un certain nombre
de pans de production qui ont perdu en
souveraineté depuis des années pour ne
pas dire des dizaines d'années je pense
aux fruits et légumes je pense à la
volaille je pense à la viande bovine
reconnaissons aussi qu'on est
puissamment exportateur en lait
puissamment exportateur en céréales
puissent spectateur
en vain et spiritueux enfin bref on a
quand même des secteurs sur lequel il y
a de l'excellence mais on a besoin de de
penser notre système y compris avec le
dérèglement climatique y compris avec
les grands dérèglements du monde
géopolitique et économiques en regardant
les facteurs qu'on a de risque qu'on a
sur notre souveraineté notre propre
souveraineté puis globalement les
facteurs de risque qu'on a sur la
souveraineté européenne et mondiale et
donc on a un travail à faire c'est le
sens de ce qu'on va annoncer au cours de
ce salon et à l'issue de ce salon sur le
plan souveraineté frisé légumes et au
fond c'est une affaire c'est un concept
général mais il faut rentrer après dans
le détail des choses pour regarder des
secteurs par secteur Production par
production les secteurs qui sont au
risque aujourd'hui on vient d'en parler
la betterave on est largement souverain
puisqu'on est le premier producteur
européen de betterave mais il y a un
risque de perte de souveraineté si nous
n'arrivons pas à trouver des solutions
techniques au-delà des mesures d'urgence
que nous prenons cette année donc il y a
un risque pour la filière betterave sur
terre il y a un risque à disparaître
aujourd'hui cette filière je ne connais
pas un système économique qui tienne
avec 30 à 40% d'une année sur l'autre de
perte de récolte et qui tiennent
durablement avec ça donc parce que vous
avez des outils industriels vous avez un
système économique comme si vous disiez
chaque année ou ça fait deux ans un
constructeur automobile il perd 40% de
sa production vous voyez bien les
raticités des choses et donc on a besoin
par la recherche de trouver des
solutions et pour trouver des
alternatives
elle pourrait arriver ces solutions
alors on dit entre deux et quatre ans
plutôt par les par les semences plutôt
par la recherche variétale pour éviter
je parle de la betterave stricto sensu
on va regarder si on peut pas on va
mettre de toute façon des moyens
supplémentaires donc c'est un temps long
et la difficulté qu'on a dans les
moments qu'on traverse c'est d'avoir un
certain nombre de gens qui qui parfois
donnent alors il y a des décisions là en
l'occurrence c'est une décision de la
Cour de justice mais un certain nombre
de gens qui sont la place publique
disent Yaka faucon c'est simple suffit
d'interdire comme si l'interdiction
entre produisait la solution
l'interdiction n'a jamais produit la
solution et donc on a besoin de
travailler dans une forme de
planification la première ministre en
parlera aujourd'hui à anticiper ce que
peuvent être le risque de disparition de
molécules à regarder toujours dans la
chimie et les produits phytosanitaires
qu'elles peuvent être les alternatives
et les autres alternatives
éventuellement mais juste entre deux et
quatre ans vous dites là vous avez
promis d'indemniser les producteurs de
betteraves qui seraient touchés par la
jaunisse cette année qu'est-ce qu'il en
sera pour les années futures est-ce que
tous les ans on est en train de regarder
sur l'année 2021 d'abord on va essayer
de couvrir les choses dans l'ordre
chronologique des problèmes qui sont à
nous d'abord couvrir 2023 parce que
pourquoi il y avait un risque qu'un
certain nombre de producteurs décident
de ne pas planter
auquel cas c'est la filière entière qui
se désagrégeait puisque les outils
transformation et les disparaît et on
est en train de regarder sur des
alternatives avec des produits qu'on
essaie on essaiera au contestera cette
année et par ailleurs à voir ce qui peut
être accéléré pour que 24 25 soit plutôt
l'horizon que 26 27 mais en attendant
tous les ans ils sont indignés on est
sur pardon je prends dans l'ordre 23
indemnisation on cherche il y a de la
recherche il y a l'INRA il y a des
instituts techniques dont je ne peux pas
vous dire le 25 février si j'ai une
solution le 25 février
indemnisation de manière illimitée
c'est-à-dire que tous les producteurs
sont touchés ceux qui sont concernés par
un épisode de Johnny c'est dont on
identifiera bien c'est bien l'objectif
que de couvrir le risque et c'est
l'engagement qu'on a pris devant eux
oui vous évoquiez monsieur le ministre
la question des bovins la France en
aurait perdu 2 millions en moins de 10
ans est-ce que par rapport au coût
écologique on parle notamment de la
ressource en eau on l'a vu encore dans
le reportage le commentaire il y a
quelques minutes ici même est-ce que par
rapport à cette moindre consommation de
viande en France c'est le sens de
l'histoire est-ce que ce n'est pas le
sens de l'histoire justement
la décroissance de production ne suis
pas de manière linéaire la décroissance
de consommation à la vérité on a une
décroissance de consommation de 1 2%
selon les années ça dépend d'ailleurs
des filières en viande bovine plus qu'on
vient de porcine par exemple puisque la
viande porcine on est plutôt en légère
augmentation et c'est bien tout le
problème de dire de ne pas corréler le
besoin en consommation de la réalité de
la production c'est une erreur il y a
une tendance générale et une tendance
lourde au niveau national ou au niveau
européen
une tendance plutôt à la diminution de
la consommation de viande il y a aussi
une tendance à au transfert parfois de
la consommation de telles production
vers telle autre par ailleurs y compris
sur les viandes y compris sur les
viandes volaille volailles viande rouge
porc viande rouge port volaille donc il
y a des mouvements à l'intérieur de ces
de ces consommations troisième élément
il va falloir qu'on se dise aussi une
chose on a besoin de l'élevage y compris
dans le process de décarbonation on a
besoin de l'élevage si je veux faire de
l'engrais minéral vers l'engrais
organique j'ai besoin d'élevage si j'ai
envie et besoin j'ai envie et besoin
d'ailleurs de maintenir les prairies qui
ont des fonctions paysagères des
fonctions biodiversité mais aussi des
fonctions de stockage carbone j'ai
besoin d'élevage et donc ce qu'il faut
qu'on arrive c'est à trouver la balance
d'un point de vue de la consommation
mais aussi qu'on trouve et qu'on montre
mieux la contribution déterminante de
l'élevage à la à la transformation et à
la transition agricole l'idée que
certains ont mis dans les têtes que le
monde irait mieux sans élevage c'est une
idée totalement saugrenue d'abord parce
que les gens et donc sauf être dans un
pays autoritaire qui dirait article 1 il
y a plus d'élevage articles d'eau on
mange plus de viande c'est pas la
volonté que nous avons alors je sais que
dans l'esprit de certains il y aurait un
peu cette volonté là c'est pas la mienne
vous en doutez et deux par ailleurs on a
besoin d'élevage il y a pas un
territoire y compris dans des régions
vous connaissez
qui ne sans élevage il y a pas d'autres
activités et donc est-ce qu'on a envie
d'aller à lambroussaillement on risque
incendie à la perte de biodiversité à la
faible faible stockage de carbone donc
il faut qu'on arrive à montrer ça et
d'ailleurs avec le président de la
République lors des échanges qu'il a eu
avec la filière avec les Chambres
d'agriculture avec la coopération nous
sommes sur leur stand l'idée c'est de
travailler sur ce qu'on appelle les
habilités qu'est-ce qu'apporte l'élevage
de positif pour les milieux pour la
biodiversité pour le climat et ça c'est
un élément important il y a deux puis de
carbone le but qui les deux culs de
carbone c'est la forêt sous tous ces
sous toutes ses variétés la haie
l'agroforesterie et la forêt puis à la
prairie et donc on a besoin de prairie
et donc on a besoin d'élevage et donc on
a besoin d'éleveurs
sur la question on en a un peu parlé
avec les betteraves mais des pesticides
des produits phytosanitaires et de leur
interdiction c'est une inquiétude
évidemment des agriculteurs le problème
c'est que ce n'est pas le cas partout
dans l'Union européenne de la même façon
est-ce que pour la principale
concurrence de l'agriculture française
aujourd'hui elle est intra-européenne
alors contrairement à ce qu'on croit
c'est parfois on dit c'est les accords
internationaux qui sont la principale
concurrence à la vérité la principale
concurrence elle est intra-européenne
c'est d'ailleurs pas nouveau il fut
d'ailleurs une période encore
aujourd'hui pour un certain nombre de
produits où nous étions dominant sur tel
ou tel marché mais la question des
produits phytosanitaires et les double
la première
c'est qu'on prépare les transitions là
où on sait qu'on aura des transitions de
on aura besoin ici nous sommes
nous-mêmes entourés de chimie et donc la
chimie il voit pas pourquoi
l'agriculture serait privée de chimique
en tout le reste de nos vies et de la
chimie c'est pas parce que c'est de la
chimique c'est toxique
donc on a introduit cette idée là on a
besoin de chimie et on a besoin par
ailleurs et je l'assume comme tel parce
que sinon sinon on raconte des sornettes
on aura besoin de ça mais on a des
produits dont on sait que le degré de
d'impact et de plus en plus faible mais
quand il y a des produits qui ont un
impact il faut assumer aussi d'avoir
nécessité en sortir et là il faut
essayer de trouver les éléments de
transition première élément ça c'est en
franco-français le problème du système
français et du système européen
d'ailleurs c'est qu'à la vérité chacun
émettre chez lui des autorisations ou
des interdictions donc on a créé petit à
petit un certain nombre de distorsions
de concurrence avec nos voisins
européens c'est le cas sur la betterave
c'est le cas sur un certain nombre
d'autres produits et souvent nous
faisons figure de précurseur on est les
premiers interdire pendant ce temps-là
les vous nos voisins et concurrents nous
font de la compétition généralement
d'ailleurs après l'union européenne nous
suit mais sauf qu'on a appris cinq ou
six ans ou 10 ans de retard de
compétitivité et donc l'idée aussi comme
une injustice par des agriculteurs mais
ils ont raison de le vivre comme une
injustice alors l'idée que j'ai
qui a été soumise au président de la
République et que j'ai proposé c'est de
dire ah il faut de la planification
c'est à dire que quand on commence à
avoir des alertes sur des molécules il
faut qu'on puisse en raison regarder les
impacts sur les filières regardez les
alternatives et assumer le délai
nécessaire sur ce soit pas un produit
dans la toxicité soit avéré et très
important pour la santé humaine mais
quand même il faut qu'on puisse assumer
les transitions et de pas de décision
qui ne se relève pas du niveau européen
si ça doit produire de l'interdiction ou
la ou la réévaluation dans les modalités
d'utilisation diable que ça se fasse au
niveau européen parce que sinon ça n'a
aucun sens d'avoir un marché unique ou
un marché commun
tous les produits circulent librement
dans l'Europe c'est à notre avantage ça
a fait partie de la puissance française
si on commence à dire tous les produits
circulent mais tous ne sont pas issus
des mêmes conditions de production et
que c'est chez nous qu'on a les
conditions les plus drastiques et les
plus pénalisantes à la fin il n'y a plus
d'agriculture ça aussi il faut quand
même se le dire et donc on a besoin
d'une harmonisation européenne et donc
tout ce qui se fera c'est le combat que
je mène
auprès des collègues européens c'est
tout ce qui fera en termes de
normalisation
positive ou négative au niveau au niveau
européen et pas ailleurs mais ça c'est
un combat qui est à long terme ça oui
mais ça n'empêche pas parce que c'est
pas un combat à long terme qu'il faut
pas le mener parce que vous leur dites
aux agriculteurs
on prend les problèmes les uns après les
autres on a un sujet betterave on a
d'autres molécules qui peuvent être
faire l'objet d'interdiction et là c'est
la recherche d'innovation et la
planification sur la question on en a un
peu parlé des fruits et légumes puisque
la France importe aujourd'hui à 40% de
ses légumes 60% de ses fruits vous avez
parlé d'un plan de souveraineté fruits
et légumes qu'est-ce qu'il va contenir
alors il va contenir alors je
l'annoncerai mercredi donc je dis
quelques éléments de ce qui va contenir
mais vous permettrez de l'annoncer aussi
avec les professionnels d'abord j'aurais
saluer le travail qui a été fait avec
les professionnels on a essayé de
comprendre ce qui était les facteurs de
perte de compétitivité il y a une
vingtaine d'années nous étions souvent
nous étions autosuffisants souverain est
autre chose nous étions autosuffisants
et petit à petit un certain nombre de
choses alors c'est un modernisation d'un
certain nombre d'outils de production je
pense au serre froide faire chauffer on
a des outils de production on a on a
perdu hors c'est des ambiances et des
milieux dans lesquels on peut se passer
de produits phytosanitaire mais les deux
chauffés ou froide les Espagnols ont 10
fois plus de cercle que nous
c'est un élément de réassurance en
termes de compétitivité deuxième élément
on a besoin de rénover pour ce qui est
des fruits plutôt là nos vergers on a
des vergers dont les variétés sont
parfois moins en adéquation avec la
tente des consommateurs plus sensible à
certaines maladies et moins facile à
être protégé parce que les systèmes de
filets et autres qu'on met dans les
vergers il faut que le verger soit
constitué pensé pour ça donc le deuxième
sujet c'est la rénovation des vergers le
troisième sujet pour ne pas aller trop
trop loin le troisième sujet c'est le
travail sur les les alternatives aux
produits phytosanitaires et donc c'est
un travail massif au travers de France
2030 parce que ça sera le filigrane des
modalités de financement qui permet
quand même de mieux tenir compte des
nécessités transition c'est le travail
qu'on fait sur les variétés c'est le
travail qu'on fait sur les alternatives
c'est travail qu'on fait sur le
biocontrôle puis dernier sujet pour
aller vite c'est un sujet de qu'on
communication on a seulement un Français
sur trois et je leur en fais pas griller
est-ce que c'est souvent une question ou
d'information ou de moyens seulement un
Français sur trois prend les cinq fruits
et légumes par jour recommandé par le
programme nutrition santé
par tous les en grands organismes l'OMS
le dit aussi on a besoin au travers de
la communication
de faire savoir et de montrer les
savoir-faire aussi sans faire de jeux de
mots mais de faire savoir qu'il est
nécessaire de consommer des fruits et
légumes alors après on a des sujets
parfois d'inflation des sujets de
consommation mais avant l'inflation et
avant la consommation nous étions déjà à
ce tour là donc on a besoin de faire la
promotion des fruits et légumes en
général et des fruits et légumes
français puisque l'objectif c'est qu'on
puisse en produire plus oui vous avez
évoqué plusieurs reprises cette question
de survie de l'agriculture française de
souveraineté 100 000 exploitations en
moins en France en une décennie il me
semble-t-il et aussi derrière des gros
soucis des gros problèmes c'est un sujet
dramatique chez les agriculteurs
eux-mêmes un problème humain on parle
d'un suicide tous les deux jours en
France vous confirmez ce chiffre
d'ailleurs c'est le chiffre
malheureusement comment vous abordez cet
aspect humain des choses alors il y a
plusieurs choses à renouvellement des
générations est une chose mais je
j'aborde le sujet humain d'abord le
monde agricole est un monde qui est
plutôt public et qui c'est pas le monde
dans lequel on exprime le plus parfois
sa détresse à désespérance sa difficulté
son impasse technique son impasse
économique ça on impasse parfois
personnel il faut que la parole se
libère il faut qu'on arrive à ce que
chaque maillon de la chaîne tout le
monde est responsable dans une chaîne
alors tout le monde est responsable pas
au sens juridique mais tout le monde
doit regarder veiller sur sur un
agriculteur celui qui s'occupe de son
élevage le vétérinaire le technicien des
chambres d'agriculture le responsable
public qui le croise à tel ou telle
manifestation le banquier l'assure enfin
tout le monde l'agent de l'État qui
saisit son dossier ou le contrôle tout
le monde doit penser qu'on est face à
des situations parfois qui sont des
situations de détresse et qui sont
dramatiques et qui parfois s'expriment
d'ailleurs par la violence y compris
physique assez rarement mais parfois
verbal mais derrière ça il peut essayer
de détecter les situations les
situations d'être assez souvent lié à
une problématique économique
pas toujours seulement souvent mais
c'est le terreau la problématique mais
maintenant vous allez avoir aussi d'un
certain nombre de gens qui donnent le
sentier ils sont dans une impasse
économique parce qu'ils sont dans une
impasse climatique donc on a dans ce
moment ou un peu rien est stable ni
économiquement ni climatiquement ni en
termes de produits utilisables il y a
quelque chose de l'ordre d'une détresse
qui peut naître puis un deuxième sujet
sur lequel j'attire l'attention de tout
le monde y compris de ceux qui je pense
pas que tout le monde soit mal
intentionné c'est pas ma nature de
penser ça mais de ceux qui disent des
choses sur l'agriculteur qui écrivent
des choses quand vous mettez sur un
bâtiment d'élevage quand de
concentration
d'élevage de volailles élevage de porc
vous vous dites quelque chose à
quelqu'un qui est d'une violence
absolument terrible au-delà de la
comment dirais du gap entre ce qui est
écrit et la réalité et la comparaison
qui n'est pas une comparaison qui est
une offense faite à ce qu'on était les
camps de concentration et ceux qui ont
été mais au-delà sont aussi elle est
victime de cette radicalisation du débat
ah oui quand vous avez des gens en bout
de champ qui vous menacent et qui vous
disent qu'est-ce que vous mettez dans le
produit quand vous avez des agriculteurs
il y en a des témoignages tous les jours
qui sont menacés physiquement parce que
le voisin demande ce que c'est compris
sans savoir quoi que ce soit de ce que
c'est de tel ou tel produit quand vous
avez des gens qui à chaque fois que vous
avez un projet vous disent j'en veux pas
la nuisance vous avez vu le cas d'un
agriculteur dans les dans les idiots où
il y a le voisinage dans un courage
immense d'anonymat parce que c'est quand
même mieux quand on est anonyme dit on
veut pas de vos vaches on préfère vous
mettiez des moutons mais on n'est pas
dans un exercice récréatif on est dans
une activité économique on est avec des
gens qui ont besoin de considération et
besoin de vivre de leur travail donc on
a quelque chose à dire y compris dans
cette question de mallette de l'amour
comporte aux agriculteurs et elle a aux
actes et du besoin qu'on a deux et si on
passe son temps à dire que au fond ils
ont des activités qui sont toxiques
parce que c'est ça ce que disent ces
gens-là ce qui est faux en plus
évidemment faut pas s'étonner après
qu'il y a des réactions qui soient des
réactions de de forteresse assiégées de
crainte d'incompréhension vous avez des
gens qui tous les jours en France il
faut rendre hommage à leur patience sont
se font engueuler on va dire le mot par
des gens qui ne connaissent rien aussi
que le végétaux et qui simplement disent
je veux une forme de tranquillité mais
faut accepter dans l'activité agricole
la part de ce qu'elle a de contrainte
pour tout le monde et c'est normal vous
avez parlé de l'école
on est dans une société qui est quand
même diablement peu bienveillante et
c'est jamais de comprendre l'autre dans
sa différence et de comprendre l'autre
dans ces contraintes et donc je demande
à tout le monde dans ses propos dans sa
manière d'aborder les choses de d'avoir
de pas être caricatural sinon ce pays on
pouvait ne pas être caricatural en sport
très mieux et de d'essayer de prendre
l'autre vous avez parlé de l'économie
qui et du climatique on va en parler
l'économique d'abord les négociations
commerciales annuelles entre producteurs
et distributeurs s'achève dans quelques
heures où on est-on dans quelques jours
jour et heure
on sait que ça glisse c'est la date
limite c'est fin février on est dans un
difficile de 48 heures donc c'est
quelques grandes heures et quelques
petits jours pour pas jouer sur les mots
on en est qu'il y a eu du retard de prix
je ne comprends pas d'ailleurs que la
grande distribution est en font pris
tant de temps pour négocier parce
qu'évidemment après c'est on concentre
sur quelques jours
la querelle de la négociation et ça
c'est évidemment très mauvais donc on a
une tension des derniers jours alors
c'est normal dans une négociation mais
quand vous avez des enseignes qui
étaient encore il y a trois ou quatre
jours j'ai réuni tout le monde à 30 ou
40% simplement de négociation achevée
vous avez évidemment une tension qui est
forte bon j'ai on a deux débats
là-dessus le premier c'est que d'abord
la loi rien que la loi au moins la loi
c'est-à-dire égalim 1 et 2 et Gallim 2
en particulier c'est on rémunère la
matière première agricole on a un
deuxième sujet qui est plus prégnant
cette année c'est la matière première
industrielle parce que la chaîne
alimentaire c'est des producteurs des
transformateurs des distributeurs tout
le monde doit gagner sa vie dans la
chaîne et à l'hym 2 et 1 viennent plutôt
essayer de améliorer le premier point et
globalement quand vous en parlez que le
secteur agricole on a plutôt fait une
oeuvre dans le bon sens personne dirait
qu'il faut revenir en arrière et qu'il
faut supprimer cette elle a été dans le
bon sens avec une forme de marche avant
sur le prix on a un sujet parce qu'il y
a des augmentations qui se sont
lentement sûrement et accélérant arriver
c'est dans la chaîne agroalimentaire
parce que ce qu'on appelle les matières
empêche les emballages le vert l'énergie
et donc on a besoin aussi que dans le
dialogue qui se noue il y a aussi un
dialogue avec la grande distribution
pour les transports les transformateurs
je dis bien qui permettent de mieux
prendre en compte les hausses qui ont
été alors faut le faire aussi avec
raison mais les transformateurs le font
et c'est ce qu'a dit le président de la
République il faut aussi que les
distributeurs distributeurs près de
l'Empa c'est-à-dire qu'il faut que
comment dirais ça se tienne avec
l'objectif que l'inflation soit aussi
aussi maîtrisée que possible mais vous
êtes optimiste sur l'issue de ces
négociations ça va aboutir c'est
enseigne par enseigne ces produits par
produit mais je vous avais décidé
aujourd'hui
on est vraiment dans un processus
continue là d'heure en heure ça peut
bouger pour les raisons vous avez évoqué
donc non mais je ne désespère pas que y
compris tous les maillons y compris le
plus abouti le plus en aval ne
comprennent que quand on est une
entreprise française on a une
responsabilité patriotique et quand on a
un patriote ce que je ne ce dont je ne
doute pas le sujet n'est pas qu'un sujet
je leur demande pas d'être évidemment
tout le monde doit gagner de l'argent
mais le sujet c'est quand même la
souveraineté alimentaire qui accepterait
qu'un jour ses anciennes soient
responsables d'une dégradation encore
plus puissante de la souveraineté ils
ont une responsabilité c'est pas les
autres la souveraineté c'est chacun
c'est les agriculteurs ils le font tous
les jours les transformateurs les
distributeurs et puis nous comme
citoyens pour ceux qui ont plus de
moyens
parce qu'il y en a qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens ça sera offense de
leur donner des conseils ou des ordres
ou des consignes et pour ceux qui le
peuvent de penser l'acte de consommation
en disant est-ce que derrière j'ai un
agriculteur derrière le produit il y a
un producteur et donc est-ce que
derrière j'ai un producteur qui rémunéré
il y a la question du panier
anti-inflation qui est travaillé par
votre collègue Olivia Grégoire alors
évidemment on comprend l'intérêt pour
les Français dans cette période
difficile mais est-ce que vous ministre
de l'Agriculture vous souhaitez qu'il ne
voit pas le jour on sait que les
agriculteurs n'y sont pas très
favorables alors on a un débat avec les
organisations agricoles mais l'objectif
que nous partageons avec Olivia Grégoire
c'est
et c'est bien ce qui a été dit
d'ailleurs y compris par le Président de
la République le panier anti-inflation
c'est pas un panier antiproduction et
anti-transformation c'est un panier sur
lesquels les distributeurs et donc tout
le sujet que nous avons à travailler
ensemble c'est de veiller à ce que ça
soit bien les distributeurs qui fassent
l'effort on sait parfois la propension
qu'ils ont à renvoyer dans les étages
plus en amont le sujet c'est un
engagement des distributeurs et c'est un
engagement qui doivent prendre et donc
sur cette base là qu'on travaille pour
regarder sur les agriculteurs si c'est
pour dire je fais un panier
anti-inflation fait sur le dos des
autres je reviens à mon problème de
rémunération et je me reviens à mon
problème de souveraineté c'est
évidemment pas l'objectif et nous sommes
tout à fait alignés là-dessus au
gouvernement l'autre question c'est la
question climatique vous l'avez dit à
une réunion qui va avoir lieu
aujourd'hui autour du ministre de la
transition écologique Christophe Béchu
sur les restrictions d’eau est-ce qu'il
y aura des restrictions d'eau pour les
agriculteurs mais à date dans un certain
nombre de départements alors d'abord on
n'est pas dans la période où
l'agriculture a besoin de plus d'eau
voyez bien d'ailleurs que un certain
nombre de départements qui vont être
balayés aujourd'hui par de l'eau et de
la neige
ça repousse dès qu'il pleut 20 mm ou 30
mm vous avez un sujet qui est de nature
différente parce que quand même là on
est les plantes ont besoin d'eau ils ont
pas besoin ils ont besoin d'eau qui
tombe du ciel d'abord et pas forcément
d'eau des nappes mais il n'empêche que
ce que va faire Christophe que nous
allons travailler avec lui c'est dans la
perspective d'un été qui peut être
difficile si la pluviométrie n'est pas
au rendez-vous comment on se prépare et
quels sont les mécanismes territoriaux
de gouvernance et dans quel ordre on
essaie de prendre les choses c'est la
prolongation de ce qu'on a fait en 2022
sauf que d'habitude on prend plutôt ses
mesures et ses anticipations au mois
d'avril mai et que là nous sommes en
février pourquoi parce que peu d'eau en
octobre novembre un peu d'eau en
décembre un peu d'eau en janvier pas
d'eau en février et donc on est dans un
quelque chose d'atypique
en termes de pluviométrie je rappelle
quand même toujours en moyenne en France
et 600 650 mm ça va bien tomber à un
moment mais on a besoin quand vous vous
êtes responsable public d'anticiper donc
on verra les mesures département par
département secteur par secteur mais
l'idée c'est plutôt de se mettre en
situation plutôt que de produire il y a
quelques départements difficultés mais
là on est plutôt sur des bonnes
pratiques et des choses qu'on peut
porter exigées
consommateurs en tant que tel sur cette
question justement d'anticiper est-ce
que l'abandon par exemple de production
très consommatrice en eau comme le maïs
est-ce que c'est leur abandon doit être
étudié d'ores et déjà mais vous avez
déjà une évolution des pratiques selon
les territoires et on voit bien
d'ailleurs que le maïs était plutôt dans
les zones à forte pluviométrie plutôt
que dans les zones à faible pluviométrie
si vous êtes dans un printemps comme là
il s'annonce c'est à dire pas d'eau du
tout c'est le blé qui va manquer d'eau
et si il pleut cet été le maïs aura de
l'eau donc caricaturer et figé un modèle
agricole uniquement dans un modèle
climatique c'est plus compliqué que ça
alors attendez évidemment on dans un
certain nombre de territoires des
productions dont on sait bien qu'elles
seront moins faciles à mettre en oeuvre
le maïs mais pas que le maïs le
maraîchage dans certains territoires
l'arborique la question qu'on a à mettre
en oeuvre c'est de la transition mais
d'ailleurs quand vous regardez dans ces
régions là les agriculteurs se sont déjà
adaptés quand vous regardez dans
attendez quand vous regardez sur la
question du maïs les variétés qu'on a
aujourd'hui sont 20 à 30 % plus économe
en eau donc c'est l'ensemble de la
panoplie des choses qu'il faut faire et
dans le travail que nous faisons c'est
un travail géographique des transitions
qui seront à l'oeuvre mais est-ce que
vous arrivez aujourd'hui à savoir quelle
production seront touchées par la
sécheresse hivernale en cours est-ce que
par exemple il y aura des conséquences
sur le blé est-ce que ça on peut déjà
dire non parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans une période où il fait frais ou la
végétation n'est pas encore repartie
parce qu'il a fait froid et où l'appel
d'eau le besoin d'eau sera sera pas
puissant comme il valait dans trois
semaines ou un mois donc on peut pas
dire aujourd'hui ça essayons de dire et
documenter les choses après il faut se
dire les choses
le blé consomme plus d'eau que le maïs
donc on va pas arrêter toutes les
productions parce qu'il y a des
productions qui ont toutes les
productions ont besoin d'eau la seule
difficulté sur le maïs c'est que ça a
besoin d'eau dans les périodes où là il
y a le moins d'eau disponible en théorie
compte tenu de ce qu'elle climat
aujourd'hui donc on a besoin de
travailler des systèmes mais dans les
systèmes fourragés les systèmes de
prairie dans les systèmes fourragés dans
les systèmes de prairie qui cet été ont
été très lourdement pénalisés si j'ai
pas du maïs ou des éléments
complémentaires pour alimenter mon
bétail j'ai plus j'ai plus d'aliments
pour le bétail donc il faut quand même
regarder ça avec raison un mot sur une
note Chris c'est la grippe aviaire
évidemment qui inquiète combien de
volailles aujourd'hui ont été abattus à
ce jour avec cet épisode de grippe
aviaire est-ce qu'il y a encore des
foyers alors il y a encore des foyers
c'est en gros environ 3008 foyers qui
étaient à dates
concernées on a eu un épisode qui s'est
passé en deux temps une montée assez
forte à l'automne qui nous a plutôt
inquiété plutôt dans les territoires
historiques des Pays de Loire
désormais maîtrisé par les mesures de
biosécurité qui ont été prises je salue
aussi l'engagement des producteurs et
des éleveurs qui ont pris des mesures de
ce qu'on appelle de détensification de
repeuplement plus programmés plus vous
voyez plus mis en oeuvre au fur et à
mesure pourquoi parce que ça permet
d'éviter le risque dans la période la
plus grande aujourd'hui on a des foyers
qui nous inquiètent en Bretagne en
particulier dans les Côtes-d'Armor avec
un sentiment qui a une progression là
dans ces territoires là
dans un mois on sera sorti je le dis en
prenant ma respiration et je sais que
les éleveurs la prennent encore plus que
moi et puis deuxième et donc on a plutôt
un épisode on avait 1400 calendrier on
est plutôt à on est à 300 à date donc
c'est quand même beaucoup moins puissant
deuxième élément on travaille aussi
au-delà des mesures sanitaires de
biosécurité sur un vaccin l'objectif
étant qu'à l'automne nous puissions
mettre à disposition un vaccin c'est
quand même mesure de biocécurité les
pratiques d'élevage et le vaccin une
manière d'essayer d'endiguer cette
épidémie cet épisode aussi cette
influence de navire qui est quand même
un élément si nous n'étions pas
intervenus la filière disparaissait en
français c'est un vaccin français c'est
un vaccin il y a des il y a des Français
il y en a d'autres il y a deux de
protocoles qui sont en cours on attend
la qualification puisque c'est des
expérimentations qui ont lieu
qui ont lieu dans toute l'Europe il y a
4 et 5 à 5 pays il y a d'autres
abattages prévus on est à combien
d'abattages aujourd'hui plusieurs
millions une dizaine de millions mais il
y a toujours des mais dès qu'il y a un
cas
et dès qu'il faut le faire on le fait
voilà on va aller protocole qui a été
décidé ce n'est jamais de gaieté de
coeur que ça se fait mais il faut qu'on
arrive à juguler cette influence va
venir on va aller retrouver Audrey Vita
ce qui est dans les allées du salon avec
à ses côtés un agriculteur Jean-Michel
Curien qui était éleveur de Ras
vosgienne et qui a une question à vous
poser monsieur le ministre oui
Jean-Michel qui touche une retraite à
800 euros car il n'a pas effectué une
carrière complète dans une exploitation
agricole même s'il a aidé ses parents
quand il était jeune avant de reprendre
l'exploitation familiale Jean-Michel un
petit mot et puis vous aviez une
question pour le ministre concernant la
réforme
oui bonjour monsieur le ministre
donc je vous pose la question par
rapport à mon cas mais qui concerne
aussi beaucoup de monde à ce moment et
qui va en concerner encore plus dans les
années qui viennent vu l'évolution du
monde agricole c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'on
va être concerné par le projet de
réforme à 1200 euros par mois pour
toutes les personnes qui ont effectué
une carrière complète et voilà
aujourd'hui toutes les personnes qui
arrêtent un métier pour se convertir
dans l'agriculture dans quelques années
il connaîtront le même problème
puisqu'ils auront ils n'auront pas de
carrière complète à la MSA et qui ne
seront pas concernés donc par la réforme
du député andrich Chassaigne qui s'est
bien qui s'est bien défendu pour
défendre une cause mais c'est vrai que
pour moi il y a des oublis dans cette
réforme quand même nous qui avons été
moi j'étais au contact de l'agriculture
de vu mon tendre mon plus jeune âge et
que j'ai fait toute ma carrière là
dedans et aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que
finalement on passe à côté des des
dernières réformes sur ce sujet merci
de votre témoignage alors faut dire les
choses comme elles sont le système
agricole le système social agricole il
était à part du système et du régime
général c'est un choix qui a été fait au
sortir de la guerre que d'avoir et moi
je trouve que c'était un bon choix
mutualité sociale agricole Régine se
passe particulier taux de cotisations
différents plus bas que les salariés ou
d'autres régimes c'est un régime
d'indépendant agricole et donc il faut
aussi assumer le fait que régime
d'indépendant agricole c'est pas tout à
fait les mêmes règles qui s'imposent
deuxième élément loi chasser la loi
Chassaigne permet d'avoir 85% du SMIC
c'est une loi je le dis d'autant plus
que nous n'aura pas échappé quand
dressage n'était pas tout à fait de
notre obédience ou de mon obéliance
politique mais c'est le président du
groupe communiste
issu du Puy-de-Dôme et tout le monde
sait l'engagement qu'il a eu et tous ces
Montser que l'unanimité a démontré quand
même que cette loi visait à amélioré les
choses
première loi chasserienne pour les chefs
d'exploitation deuxième loi chassienne
pour les conjoints collaborateurs et les
aidants familiaux on avait des gens qui
avaient aidé
et dont la carrière n'était pas comprise
troisième élément parce que c'est un
processus continu d'amélioration et
c'est plusieurs centaines d'euros sans
200 300 pour un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs qui touchait vraiment une
retraite qui était beaucoup trop faible
elle reste trop faible mais c'est quand
même un process d'amélioration regardons
nous on part troisième texte le texte
dit Julien dive loi div qui vient d'être
voté par l'Assemblée nationale et le
Sénat lui il vient résoudre quelque
chose c'est là que le régime était
particulier dans le régime agricole
c'était toute la carrière qui était
compté pour calculer votre pension de
retraite là on introduit 25 années on a
besoin avec la MSA et c'est le cas de
Monsieur d'ailleurs de reconstituer les
carrières parce que il est facile de
reconstituer quand la carrière s'est
fait tout à fait sous régime agricole
quand elle est pas complètement sous
régime agricole il faut pouvoir
reconstituer mais on va passer à 25
années c'est à dire qu'on va réaligner
vers le régime en général et dernier
élément dans la réforme que porte
Olivier du soft que porte le
gouvernement
il y avait un trou donc petit à petit on
essaie de réparer les oublis les trous
les injustices mais il faut assumer le
fait sinon il faut qu'on parle des
cotisations faut assumer le fait que le
régime de cotisations était différent du
régime d'autres
salariés ou d'autres indépendants
dernier point dans la réforme qui est
portée là et qui va être examiné au
Sénat c'est il y a un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs qui ont dû arrêter leur
carrière notamment pour des raisons
d'arrêt de maladie et ça interrompait la
carrière ça leur faisait pas une
carrière complète elle ça leur
permettait pas d'accéder à un certain
nombre de prestations en termes de
retraite et donc là on va le mettre pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait moins
d'injustice aussi donc c'est un régime
de nature particulière on le fait
converger on s'approche des choses mais
ça n'empêche pas que évidemment il
faudrait que ça soit un processus
continue que sur lequel il faut
travailler merci Monsieur le Ministre un
mot Audrey rapidement
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez justement
de la réponse du ministre et je vous
récupère l'oreillette
oui alors qu'est-ce que j'en pense bah
je connais un peu le fonctionnement de
la mutualité sociale agricole mais après
vous aviez dit vous avez dit début de
votre intervention que ça s'est mis en
place après guerre bon moi je pense que
quand même il y a il y a des choses qui
ont évolué depuis
pardon nous en zone de montagne on était
obligé de rester sur les petites fermes
qu'on a fait qu'on a pu faire évoluer
avec beaucoup de mal parce que c'est pas
facile non plus des endroits il y a
beaucoup de pression foncières on trouve
principalement du terrain et les terres
pour exploiter donc en fait on a quand
même fait dans mon cas et je suis pas le
seul hein on a quand même fait notre
carrière complète au cul des vaches
comme on peut dire et puis aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit qu'on est quand même un
peu oublié alors ben oui je renouvelle
ma question est-ce que les fameux 1200
euros pour tout le monde est-ce qu'on va
être on est ou pas le ministre vous a
répondu on verra donc dans le
déroulement dans l'examen de la retraite
au Sénat voilà Oriane pour cette
question sur les retraites agricoles un
dernier mot Marc fait notre très
rapidement sur cet examen vous aussi
comme le président de la République vous
attendez des améliorations du Sénat il
faut qu'il enregistre le texte et c'est
1200 euros sur lesquels vous êtes
rappelé on a précisé les choses sur
carrière complète dans des régimes enfin
bref c'est des jours bref on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir mais
j'attends et d'ailleurs j'attends sans
impatience et sans inquiétude le fait
que d'abord océan puisse avoir un débat
sur un je pense que la démocratie et le
Parlement mérite des débats il faut et
je connais bien le Sénat comme vous le
savez nous je n'en doute pas donc on a
besoin d'abord que les choses soient
posées sans invective sans chanter sans
crier sans insulter sans menacer enfin
bref on est obligé de le rappeler quand
même y compris sur des plateaux de
télévision parce que ça paraît plus
naturel mais le Sénat va remettre
peut-être un peu d'ordre dans les idées
et un peu l'église au milieu du village
qui vous permettez cette expression
deuxième élément ça permettra d'aller au
fond des dossiers d'explorer le je me
sens dans quel cadre il se met
d'explorer les dates butoir les 43-44 le
débat infernal sur ce sujet là il faut
qu'on essaie d'expliciter de regarder
sur les carrières longues de regarder
sur les distorsions qui peuvent encore
exister pour les femmes donc j'espère
bien que ça permettra d'avancer sur des
projets d'avancer d'affiner le
dispositif et de d'éclairer nos
concitoyens sur les enjeux de cette
réforme merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin on passe au club
des territoires